نبدا المنتصف بتطورات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث ذكر مسؤولون اوكرانيون ان
القوات الروسيه شنت اليوم هجوما صاروخيا
وصفته بالاوسع منذ الحرب على مدن ومقاطعه
اوكرانيه استهدف فيها منشات الطاقه
والمباني السكنيه
بشان القصف الروسي قال متحدث باسم الاداره
العسكريه بالعاصمه الاوكرانيه ان الدفاعات
الجويه اسقطت سبعه وثلاثين صاروخا روسيا
من اصل 40 في كتاب اليوم واضاف المسؤول
الاوكراني ان الهجوم صاروخيه اليوم هو احد
اكبر الهجمات الروسيه منذ بدايه الحرب
وفقا للمسؤولين الاوكرانيين فان قواتهم
رصدت اطلاقا نحو 60 صاروخا روسيا من
طائرات الاستراتيجيه ومن اسطول البحر
الاسود في اكياس قال عمداتها ان في جارات
حدثت شرقيه العاصمه والحقت اضرار بالبنيه
التحتيه للطاقه وتسببت بانقطاع امدادات
المياه في معظم المناطق كما اوقفت حركه
المترو كون انفاقه استخدمت
فقالت السلطات والاوكرانيه ان الهجوم
الصاروخيه الروسيه ادى الى انقطاع تام
للتيار الكهربائي اما جنوبا فطال الهجوم
الصاروخي الروسي ومناطق وبل ومدنا في
مقاطعات اوديس ونيكوليف وزافيروج
وعقب القصر الروسي قال وزير الطاقه
الاوكراني هيرمان نيجا لوشينكو انه ستكون
هناك انقطاعات للتيار الكهربائي بسبب حدوث
انخفاض في القدره على توليد وان التسعه
منشات الطاقه منشات للطاقه تضررت في جنوبي
والشرق اوكرانيا جراء القصف الروسي الذي
استهدف البنيه التحتيه في اثناء اعلنت
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه العمل بنظام انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي الطارئ في جميع انحاء
البلاد بسبب استهداف منشات الطاقه في شان
موازن قال وزير الطاقه الاوكرانيه ان
المفاوضات بشان طاقه منزوعه السلاح حول
محطه
نوويه شديده الصعوبه وفققه تعبير